jean pierre raffarin l'a franchi est
l'invité ce soir de preuve par trois
affranchi du bilan de nicolas sarkozy
vous avez pointé récemment les cinq
occasions manquées de son quinquennat et
de la campagne présidentielle nadège
plus jacques de la fp notre partenaire
reviendra sur ces critiques et vous
interrogera également sur la situation à
l'ump
et puis l'actualité du sénat la réforme
récente des modes de scrutin les chances
de la droite de reprendre le chemin en
2014 toutes ces questions vous seront
posées dans la dernière partie de
l'émission par mickaël szames s de
public sénat
et puis comme toutes les semaines les
téléspectateurs peuvent intervenir dans
l'émission en posant leurs questions via
notre partenaire dailymotion alors jean
pierre raffarin faible mobilisation
aujourd'hui contre l'accord sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi dans les rues
et puis le projet de loi du gouvernement
qui va en découler ce que laissait le
signe que le climat social en france
n'est pas si explosif que ça bonsoir
madame soir à tous je pense que le
climat social est explosif
je suis assez préoccupé de la situation
sociale dans le pays
cette manifestation est un modeste
signal mais il y en aura d'autres hélas
parce que la situation est grave on a un
déficit de croissance
on a une croissance qui aujourd'hui veut
dire déficit budgétaire puisque on ne va
pas atteindre l'objectif de croissance
on a une voie à sens il va falloir oui
mais comment va pas l'atteindre ça veut
dire déficit budgétaire ça veut donc
dire des impôts nouveaux
et tout ça dans un contexte économique
global difficile avec je pense une crise
industrielle comme on en a rarement vu
notamment dans le secteur automobile
et si je prends le secteur agricole une
crise de l'élevage très profond donc
vous avez une crise de l'emploi
auxquelles va s'ajouter la crise des
impôts la crise de la classe moyenne qui
va pas supporter qu'on fasse appel à des
impôts nouveaux pour équilibrer le
budget donc au fond avec s'échapper
entre amis je pense qu'on ne peut pas y
échapper puisqu'au fond les équations
budgétaires telles qu'elles ont été
bâties par l'exécutif ne sont pas
atteignables et donc il va falloir
remplir les caisses de l'état autrement
que par la croissance
dire par l'impôt comme il n'y a pas de
réforme pour faire des économies de
l'état qui sont actuellement à l'étude
qu'on puisse se préparer discuter on
voit bien qu'on est dans une situation
au fond qui peut être explosif parce
qu'elle a trois ingrédients
d'abord la crise de l'emploi ensuite la
crise de la fiscalité c'est à dire
l'alliance dans le mécontentement des
couches populaires et des classes
moyennes
et puis le fait que les couches qui
devait soutenir le parti s'est couché
sociales qui sont ses habituels soutient
l'éducation
les fonctionnaires sont actuellement en
grand ces petits smith en grands doutes
vis-à-vis de la politique socialiste
donc au fond le gouvernement n'a plus
d'assise populaire on voit dans les
sondages la cote de popularité
bath et donc il ya une vraie inquiétude
alors si ce mécontentement social ne se
manifeste pas dans la rue il se
manifestera l'année prochaine dans les
rues
est-ce qu'il faut méditer par exemple
l'exemple italien mario monti bien sujet
par l'austérité
je pense qu'il ya un risque très
important de populisme et on voit que ce
qui est arrivé en italie pourrait très
bien nous arriver chez nous on voit les
campagnes de madame le pen et de
monsieur mélenchon est donc au fond ces
personnes qui ne sont pas un enfant ne
sont pas des partis je pense que c'est
sous deux formes de protestation qui
notamment ont des propositions que je
qualifie de populis et dire raisonnable
quand il s'agit de quitter l'europe par
exemple comme le dit ma peine et comme
le dit monsieur mélenchon donc ceux ci
ne sont pas pour moi des partis de
gouvernement ce sont des partis
protestataires alors les ont des
origines historiques très différents
donc ils ne peuvent pas être assimilée
mais ils ont la même protestation anti
européenne qui a c'est toute la faveur
du populisme italien ces dernières
france le mario monti français je pense
que en effet si l'on voit cette campagne
se dessiner donc c'est l'intérêt de
personne que le gouvernement socialiste
va en grande difficulté au seuil je suis
de l'opposition je veux gagner les
prochaines élections
mais je suis très inquiet de la
situation dans lequel se trouve
aujourd'hui les socialistes ce que je
vois arriver la crise économique et je
ne vois rien comme mesures efficaces
notamment pour répondre à ce que mes
vous attendez quoi à st gallois la même
chaque de compétitif y est
de vérité est ce que vous attendez qu'il
vient de parler devant les français à la
télévision j'attends est ce que vous
attendez que le gouvernement prononce le
mot rigueur est tabou dans la classe
politique française à droite comme à
gauche attend pas de discours que
j'attends de l'action j'attends un plan
national pour la compétitivité
j'attends un plan qui soit vraiment à la
hauteur du rapport gallois vous savez il
a été annoncé à l'automne et il n'y a
rien dedans il ya une seule mesure est
une mesure sur lesquels le gouvernement
a fait beaucoup de communication c'est
le crédit d'impôt peut-être que le
crédit d'impôt sera utile à l'abri
d'honneur à la fin de l'année ce crédit
d'impôt je pense que le budget
d'ailleurs n'en compte plus que ça mais
ce sera pour l'année prochaine
le crédit d'impôt c'est ce qu'on va
recevoir à la fin de l'année mais qu'est
ce que c'est que la compétitivité la
compétitivité c'est un prix de revient
un entrepreneur au mois de février
aujourd'hui au mois de mars
un entrepreneur est ce qu'il va baisser
ses prix de revient est pour être
compétitif par rapport à ses concurrents
français ou étrangers alors qu'il ne
sait pas quelle va être sa recette
en ce qui concerne le crédit d'impôt
donc on le crée le crédit le crédit
d'impôt c'est absolument un une mesure
pour la compétitivité en 2013 ce sera
peut-être utile pour la trésorerie des
entreprises en 2014 dans le meilleur des
cas c'est pas financé mais en tout cas
rien n'est fait aujourd'hui pour
améliorer la compétitivité des
entreprises
tout se passe comme si l'exécutif
n'était pas conscient de la crise
industrielle de la vie tempête
industriel qui est annoncé pour le pays
est important le projet de loi sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi dont on parlait
au début de l'émission est ce que cet
acte est ce que cet accord vous convient
ce que vous vous seriez prêt à le voter
s'il est utile je le voterai il est
utile c'est une bonne étape mais ne
faisons pas croire aux français que
c'est la solution c'est une étape dans
la bonne direction d'une certaine
flexisécurité un peu plus de souplesse
donner aux entreprises tout en
protégeant les droits essentiels des
salariés donc j'admire d'une certaine
manière le courage car la cfdt de signer
un accord de cette nature qui on le voit
bien par l'apport à la démagogie de la
cgt haute force ouvrière impose à la
cfdt de montrer son esprit de
responsabilité ce qu'elle fait avec
audace mais il est clair
qu'est ce que vous avez l'impression que
françois hollande finalement se renie
par rapport à ses engagements de
campagne où est-ce qu'au contraire elle
fait preuve de pragmatisme
il est incapable de tenir les
engagements de campagne parce que nos
fonds sa campagne a été quelque part une
tromperie et nous a fait croire qu'il
suffisait de chasser sarkozy pour
chasser la crise ils ont chassé sa zee
maison toujours la crise et aujourd'hui
on voit bien que le parti socialiste
s'attendait à ce que les choses se
redressent d'elle-même et elle ne serait
ne ressent pas d'elle-même
s'il n'y a pas des réformes de structure
très importante
le parti socialiste n'y arrivera pas ils
ont supprimé une mesure qui était
essentiel le non remplacement d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux qui part à la
retraite
ils seront obligés d'y revenir et parle
aujourd'hui d'augmenter la tva
ils n'ont pas voulu appliquer la mesure
que nicolas sarkozy avait fait voter sur
la tva anti délocalisation ils devront
la faire ils sont face à une de face à
un mur aujourd'hui on parle du mur aux
états unis là nous avons un mur
industriels si nous voulons franchir ce
mur il faut baisser nos charges et pour
cela il faut faire des efforts et
notamment des efforts comme la tva anti
délocalisation et quand françois
hollande réaffirme son objectif
d'inverser la courbe du chômage il l'a
redit hier en déplacement à dijon
indique ce doit être une cause de
cohésion nationale
est ce que vous le soutenez mais bien
sûr que c'est une cause de cohésion
nationale et on ne peut que soutenir le
président quand il se bat pour l'emploi
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que le
gouvernement aujourd'hui ne prend pas
les mesures à la hauteur des engagements
du président et que c'est le
gouvernement qui va faire trébucher le
président parce que le gouvernement
aujourd'hui n'a pas un plan national de
compétitivité il y a urgence
il est incroyable de penser que les
députés socialistes les sénateurs
socialistes circulent sur le terrain
tous les jours et ne voit pas toutes ces
pme aujourd'hui du secteur automobile
qui connaissent des difficultés majeures
mais ces problèmes de compétitivité jean
pierre raffarin ne sont pas nouveaux
pourquoi les sénateurs de droite les
députés de droite quand il était au
pouvoir n'ont pas aidé les industriels
français à surmonter ces difficultés là
vous n'avez pas lu le rapport de la cour
des comptes qui dit que depuis 2010 le
gouvernement de nicolas sarkozy avait
pris les bonnes mesures
on peut discuter le bilan économique
nicolas sarkozy 2007 2010
à partir de 2006 moins sûr
à partir de minuit c'est à dire à partir
de la crise vous voyez toutes les
mesures qui sont saluées par la cour des
comptes notamment je vous le disais le
remplacement d'un fonctionnaire sur deux
qui part à la retraite et aussi la
mesure tva antidélocalisation donc le
gouvernement précédent avait pris des
mesures pourquoi les socialistes sont
ils revenus sur ces mesures
on voit bien qu'ils vont être obligés de
chercher régulièrement là on dit 6,6
milliards il faut trouver ce milliard
d'économies est en fait il faut trouver
30 à 35 milliards d'économies et donc on
voit bien que le gouvernement a besoin
d'un plan national de compétitivité il a
détricoté celui nicolas sarkozy n'a rien
mis à la place françois hollande vous
l'avez souligné tout à l'heure est au
plus bas de sa cote de popularité il a
prévu de faire maintenant tous les mois
un déplacement de deux jours pour rester
au contact des français
est ce que c'est la bonne formule vous
qui êtes un homme de communication pour
reconquérir l'opinion finalement est ce
que ce n'est pas dur même quand on veut
être un président normal de rester au
contact de la réalité
franchement je pense que c'est pas être
au contact de la réalité que de croire
que le prêt dans la république pourra
redresser sa cote de popularité par une
attitude de communication ce que les
français attendent c'est de l'action
et donc c'est au gouvernement
aujourd'hui de montherlant je vois que
les institutions fonctionnent à peu à
l'envers c'est monsieur hollande est en
train d'aller essayer de sauver monsieur
ayrault au fond c'est monsieur ayrault
et le gouvernement qui devrait protéger
le président donc on devrait entendre le
gouvernement aujourd'hui sur la bataille
de l'emploi sur la bataille de la
compétitivité et le soutien aux pme
bien évidemment que cette crise elle
était antérieure puisque les parties au
fond de 2008 2010 mais on voit bien
aujourd'hui l'extrême gravité de cette
crise et il ya une attitude qui
laisserait penser qu'il suffit que
d'envoyer le président en province pour
arranger les choses
on arrangera les choses que sur la range
les marges des entreprises l'emploi et
dans les marges des entreprises
finalement le quinquennat les choses
s'accélèrent et qu'on revient seul et
même style de présidence l'omniprésident
non je pense que c'est une fragilité et
on a intérêt à ce que le président de la
république soit crédible dans d'autres
pays
même l'opposition a intérêt à ce que
monsieur hollande représente bien les
intérêts de la france
les aspirations des français et donc
nous n'avons pas intérêt à fragiliser le
président que le président mène des
actions comme allait passer 48 heures en
province est utile et je pense que c'est
l'occasion pour lui de s'exprimer et
d'être en phase avec le pays
mais sur le fond des choses c'est au
gouvernement aujourd'hui de regarder
avec lucidité la vague de tempête
industrielle qui s'annonce devant nous
et pour lequel il faut protéger la
france de cette vague là or on ne voit
rien venir regarder au sénat on nous
propose des lois électorales on nous
propose un certain nombre d'initiatives
et y compris d'ailleurs le mariage pour
tous et quelques autres projets de
société nous sommes face à une grande
vague de tempête industriels face à nous
et on fait comme si elle n'arrivait pas
et il arrive tout le monde la voit la
motion de censure déposée par
jean-françois copé ou qu'il va déposer à
l'assemblée nationale a du sens dans ce
contexte là pour débattre des finances
publiques et la cena beaucoup de chance
parce que moi je crois que l'opposition
ne doit pas se contenter de critiquer
monsieur hollande où monsieur ayrault
nous devons proposer parce que si le
populisme arrive comme à lesdins italie
ceux qui sont pour et ceux qui sont
contre seront emportés dans la même
protestation nous il faut qu'on montre
bien on a une autre politique une autre
politique d'économies sur les charges
sociales parlementaire pour des propos
je pense qu'il faut un discours de
politique économique un discours de
politique générale pour l'économie et ça
c'est une motion de censure
donc j'attends du président de mon parti
que pour la motion de censure et nous
dégage les grandes lignes de ce que
serait la politique économique de l'ump
si on était au pouvoir
en quoi elle serait différente de celle
de monsieur ayrault et en quoi elle
répondrait aux problèmes des français
nous attendons pour le débat de censure
un discours du président de l'ump sur
notre politique économique et nous y
travaillons les uns les autres
la concertation est engagée pour
assembler les meilleures idées
allez jean pierre raffarin on va parler
l'ump d'un jack de la lfp va nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau on a
l'impression qu'un vent d'émancipation
souffle à tous les étages de l'ump en ce
moment le droit d'inventaire est tout
vert notamment par vous vous avez parlé
des cinq occasions manquées de nicolas
sarkozy pendant son quinquennat et
pendant la campagne présidentielle mais
également par aussi l'ancien premier
ministre
nicolas sarkozy françois fillon qui
n'hésite pas à se mettre maintenant au
même niveau que l'ancien chef d'état
dans la course vers 2017 je vous propose
de regarder ce reportage de jérôme
rabier nicolas sarkozy leur a appris la
politique décomplexer les leaders de
l'ump compte désormais l'appliquer
quitte à remettre en cause le leadership
de l'ancien chef de l'état
xavier bertrand ira la primaire de 2016
bruno le maire évoque un devoir d'agir
en amène tôt et françois fillon
n'hésitent plus à se mettre à égalité
avec nicolas sarkozy en cas de retour de
ce dernier
tout est à reconstruire il faut d'abord
construire le projet et puis on verra
ensuite celui qui est mieux à même de le
porter j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire
que la pression c'était nicolas sarkozy
elle je soutiendrai nicolas sarkozy et
si en l'occurrence c'est moi qui suis à
même de mieux le porter et aujourd'hui
intense je m'élancerai s'affranchir de
la tutelle de l'ancien chef sans pour
autant froisser les militants ump qui ou
encore en lui le meilleur recours pour
la tâche n'est pas aisée d'autant que
certains gardiens du temple sarkozyste
comme le courant de la droite forte
arrivés en tête lors des dernières
élections internes ne compte pas laisser
enterrer leur leader spirituel
ce qui est incontestable c'est qu'on a
besoin du talent de rendre sa copie du
talent de françois fillon mais que le
leader naturel de la droite française
pour moi et pour nous ça respect que la
sarkozie était un problème de leadership
ou cinq jours
si on râle de leadership
ils arriveront dans un puits ce qui
s'appelle nicolas sarkozy pour
s'émanciper les leaders de l'ump doivent
aussi réapprendre à gagner sans nicolas
sarkozy c'est la stratégie du président
actuel de l'ump qui compte s'appuyer sur
des victoires électorales pour s'imposer
mais normal que certain nombre de mes
amis ou de mes aînés se préoccupe de
2017 moi je pense que la priorité pour
nous c'est le rendez vous de 2014 ne pas
se tromper on ne peut pas imaginer de
l'emporter en 2017 si nous n'avons pas
d'abord retrouver les français à
l'occasion des municipales de 2014 et
ensuite des cantonales et les régionales
ne pas parler de 2017 pour éclipser
l'idée d'un retour n'empêchera pas de
s'interroger sur les échecs du passé
il faudra pour certains analystes
politiques faire l'inventaire de ce qui
n'a pas fonctionné
il y a un devoir d'inventaire de la part
des dirigeants de droite y compris
nicolas sarkozy lui-même
le jour où une déciderait de revenir qui
dit inventaire d'y relever tous les bons
aspects qu'il faudra mettre en avant
avec fierté auprès des sympathisants
mois et puis aussi reconnaître les
erreurs on ne perd pas systématiquement
toutes les élections comme nicolas
sarkozy les a perdus tout au long de son
quinquennat sans pouvoir sans avoir à
faire ce type d'inventaire c'est sur
cette base qu'un nouveau projet doit
être inventées à l'ump
une manière dix mois après la défaite
présidentielle dont l'un avancé
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur raffarin
alors comme on vient de le voir au début
de ce reportage vous êtes nettement
démarquée de l'ancien président nicolas
sarkozy il ya quelques jours dont le
test que vous avez publié
vous lui reprochez sa droitisation
pendant la campagne alors vous savez
j'ai relu les déclarations vous faisiez
au moment de la présidentielle
vous étiez déjà très critique je ne suis
pas d'accord avec nicolas sarkozy sur
beaucoup de choses mais ce n'est pas le
moment de contredire sa stratégie c'est
ce que vous disiez entre les deux tours
alors vos critiques d'aujourd'hui sont
cohérentes avec celles d'hier mais
pourquoi les faire maintenant alors que
monsieur sarkozy n'est n'est pas sur le
devant de la scène
il ne sera peut-être dans deux ans mais
pour l'instant il ne l'est pas le timing
n'est certainement pas ainsi qu'une
question de timing fait quoi mais je
n'aime pas tirer contre mon camp donc
moi j'ai fait un rêve
entre monsieur sarkozy tous nos métiers
j'ai fait un livre en 2007 qui était une
lettre ouverte à nicolas sarkozy je lui
ai dit la ligne qui me paraissaient de
la ligne humaniste pour la france
j'ai refait un livre en 2011 2012 avant
les élections après donc j'ai écrit et
tout ce que j'ai dit le changement de
premier ministre
au fond la stratégie de droitisation je
me suis exprimé sur tous ces sujets mais
il est clair que c'est pas dans une
campagne électorale que j'allais a
formulé un certain nombre de critiques
parce que je vais vous dire un secret je
critiquais monsieur sarkozy mais je
préférais monsieur sarkozy à monsieur
hollande
donc il ya un moment vous cherchez la
valeur absolue vous cherchez le meilleur
et puis un autre moment où vous prenez
celui qui est préférable donc entre
sarkozy et hollande je n'avais pas
d'hésitation je préférais sarkozy c'est
pour ça que j'ai attendu après les
élections pour pouvoir m'exprimer sur
ces sujets mais ce qui compte maintenant
c'est d'être crédible en 2010 est que
nos propositions nos promesses soient
crédibles aux yeux des électeurs
pour cela il faut qu'on reconnaisse nos
erreurs il ya eu des choses bien faites
par nicolas sarkozy ait eu un certain
nombre de choses qu'il était moins bien
il faut regarder tout cela avec lucidité
pour gagner en crédibilité
il faut regarder vous avez monsieur
balladur dit c'est à nicolas sarkozy lui
même de faire son inventaire pour vous
le faire c'est à vous c'est à l'ump
c'est un monsieur sarkozy lui-même
je pense que tout responsable politique
doit analyser sa propre part de
responsabilité donc moi je suis pas du
tout hostile par exemple à ce qu'on ait
un regard sur les dix ans pas seulement
et cinq ans de nicolas sarkozy mais
aussi des 50 jacques chirac et choeurs
et donc qu'on puisse dire clairement on
a réussi des choses on a échoué sur
d'autres et qu'au fond la confiance des
français
naîtra de notre crédibilité c'est à dire
de notre lucidité
est ce que vous faites partie des
nombreuses personnes qui rendent visite
à monsieur sarkozy dans ses bureaux
parisiens miromesnil je lui ai rendu
visite une fois en un an et voudrait
parler justement de ce problème ces
questions mais vous savez nicolas
sarkozy a été mon ministre
il a été aussi mon président et donc
j'ai beaucoup discuté avec lui à maintes
reprise et que nous avons une relation
dirait que très décomplexée et qui
n'exclut pas les relations amicales mais
mais c'est au fond un discours franc
puisque on se connaît très bien
l'un et l'autre et qu'on peut pas
tricher l'un par rapport à langer de
venir se connaît bien
comme vous vous connaissez très bien à
votre avis est-ce qu'il peut revenir
je pense que ça dépendra des
circonstances je crois que ce serait une
erreur d'avoir une stratégie de conquête
je pense que ce sont les circonstances
qui peuvent appeler nicolas sarkozy et
que dans cette hypothèse là il est tout
à fait envisageable que je sois amenés à
voter une troisième fois lection
présidentielle pour lui mais ça dépendra
des circonstances qu'est ce que ces
circonstances c'est à dire que monsieur
hollande n'est pas réussi à redresser la
france que messieurs fillon et copé ce
soit entre tuer si je peux m'exprimer
ainsi jeu qu'est ce que c'est je pense
qu'à un moment on voit que le parti
socialiste a échoué et que la seule
vraie alternative c'est un rassemblement
autour de l'ancien président si tel est
le cas je pense que à ce moment là se
dégagera dans le pays une volonté
d'alternance au tour de nicolas sarkozy
donc nous le verrons mais ça disons que
c'est un horizon 2016
c'est à dire un an avant les élections
présidentielles et lui même envie vous
croyez je ne sais pas les deux signaux
contraires sont envoyés de temps en
temps on le voit penser à autre chose
voyager à voir d'autres horizons et de
temps en temps on le voit très sensible
quelques rendez vous est donc tout prête
à bondir donc mais je le vire s est
toujours là je pense je crois que quand
on a le virus s'est assez vite et je
pense qu'ils ne lâcheront pas rester
comme ça mais au fond on voit bien que
pour notre ressource humaine à l'ump on
a aujourd'hui des personnalités qui
peuvent prétendre à la fonction et il y
a non pas trop je pense que les trois
qui sont les plus anciennes en à jean
françois copé pour lui il ya un horizon
qui était très clair c'est celui des
municipales lui doit conduire l'ump à la
victoire aux municipales c'est son
travail c'est sa mission et s'ils
réussissent à s'en doute qu'il pourra
monter une marche ensuite donc lui il a
une échéance gagné 2014
françois fillon lui la crédibiliser un
projet politique donc il va aller à
l'eau
devant les français pour construire un
projet politique et essayer de faire en
sorte que et il entend je dirais en
communication avec le pays sur ce projet
là donc on va voir ce que ça donne et
puis nicolas sarkozy lui qui devra
peut-être répondre à des circonstances
que nous ne connaissons pas aujourd'hui
donc finalement ils ne sont pas vraiment
concurrents dans leur parcours ils
pourraient être concurrents à un moment
donné mais pour le moment chacun son
parcours
donc je souhaite que les uns et les
autres nous respections le parcours des
uns et des autres et qu'on soit pas déjà
gisent à coeur sa trace voilà chacun
dans son couloir
bon alors on va parler de l'ump si vous
le voulez bien pendant la crise vous
avez été un intermédiaire entre les deux
rivaux jean françois copé françois
fillon et vous avez réussi apparemment
les réconcilier alors est ce que c'est
une vraie réconciliation ou une
réconciliation de façade en disant que
c'est une vraie réconciliation mais
progressive
il est clair que la confiance avait été
rompu donc il faut être franc je suis
franc avec vous la confiance entre été
rompu et que nous sommes là dans une
situation de convalescence on n'est pas
dans une confiance rétabli complètement
mais il ya beaucoup de progrès qui sont
faits les équipes se réunissent toutes
les semaines on se réunit le lundi soir
pour les statures se réunit le mardi
matin dans l'équipe dirigeante
on se réunit ensuite le mercredi en
bureau politique donc on s'apprivoise
les uns les autres et au fond la
confiance est en train de revenir et je
souhaite que nous travaillons à cette
confiance parce que nous avons besoin
des uns et des autres pour essayer de
renouveler l'offre ump vous avez réussi
à vous monsieur juppé malheureusement
pour lui avait échoué et qu'il était
au-dessus craie qu'est ce que vous leur
avez dit à ces deux hommes pour qu'ils
se réconcilient ou en moi qui va semble
enfin en tous les cas c'est l'impression
qu'ils étaient tous les deux bien
conscients qu'ils étaient en train de
s'abîmer fortement et donc avec d'autres
g j'ai multiplié les alertes sur le fait
qu' on n'avait pas intérêt à ce qu'il
s'auto détruise qu'au fond moi j'avais
voté copé mais je n'avais pas intérêt
pour mon parti à ce que la carte fillon
disparaissent on peut avoir besoin dans
l'avenir de françois fillon beaucoup de
gens avait d'ailleurs voté pour jean
françois copé pour la présidence du
parti pensons que françois fillon
pouvait être un candidat à la
présidentielle et d'autres gens pensent
que jean françois copé à cet avenir donc
les uns et les autres ont un potentiel
ce que je ne voulais pas c'est qu'il
s'auto détruisent et qu'on perd nos
chances d'avenir vous savez le
quinquennat accélère terriblement les
choses je pense que au lendemain des
municipales au lendemain 2014
on va réparer la présidentielle et là il
nous faudra un candidat crédible mais
justement du coup certains militants ump
s'interroge est-ce qu'il faut repartir
sur un nouveau vote pour la présence de
l'ump en septembre prochain puisque
c'est dans l'accord je suis favorable à
ce nouveau vote mais ce que j'entends
aujourd'hui c'est que les militants ne
le souhaite pas et qu'au fond tout le
monde va être dans l'élection municipale
et que les listes sont pas faciles à
faire et si en plus de cette difficulté
de composition des listes il faut
ajouter le clivage copé fillon
ça va rendre les choses encore plus
complexe donc les têtes de listes à 80 %
vont être désignés pour les élections
municipales au mois de mai est donc en
septembre on sera dans la composition
des listes municipales plus que dans la
bataille électorale ne semble type mais
c'est dans l'accord donc il faut que les
uns et les autres on respecte l'accord
je voudrais vous poser une dernière
question s'il vous plaît messieurs copé
fillon veulent tous les deux être on
sait bien président de la république
à l'avenir on sait pas quand tous les
cas ils n'ont pas la même stratégie pour
y parvenir
où on avoue nous vous en avez parlé tout
à l'heure d'ailleurs de leur stratégie
un monsieur copé dit que pour gagner le
2017 il faut déjà de gagner 2014
monsieur fillon et vise directement la
primaire de 2016 selon que la meilleure
stratégie
moi je crois qu'ils ont une bonne
stratégie chacun l'un pour l'autre
françois fillon s'est abîmé dans cette
bataille électorale et s'est abîmé par
ce que il ya eu échangé des coups et
puis il avait une image rassembleur et
donc je pense qu'il doit venir mais donc
donc pour françois fillon l'essentiel si
aujourd'hui de porter un projet est
d'essayer de le construire avec les
français et reconstruire son image de
rassembleur
c'est ça pour lui que l'essentiel donc
de partir en province discuter avec les
gens en région et apporter des réponses
aux préoccupations des français
ça c'est sont en jeu l'enjeu du projet
jean françois copé il a été élue à la
tête d'un parti donc c'est un manager
lui doit faire travailler les équipes et
doit faire en sorte que s'il ne s'agit
pas pour lui de bâtir un projet
personnel
il s'agit de gagner une bataille
collective
nous gagnons les municipales donc jean
françois a une échéance les celle de
2014 il a une et a sauté et si la sauce
bien et pourrait continuer de l'addition
premier ce que vous dites monsieur
raffarin ya pas de raison alors pour
monsieur fillon d'aller à la présidence
de l'ump en septembre ça si je suis bien
votre raisonnement c'est à sète à
françois fillon de le dire et moi je
respecte sa décision
je ne donne pas de conseils à françois
fillon il est un grand garçon il sait
faire qu'est ce que vous préférez
je ne suis pas sûr que cette auprès de
moi qui les prendraient mais en tout cas
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que je
partage sa stratégie qui est de vouloir
construire un projet avec les français
et dans cette dynamique là une bataille
partisane ne me paraît pas approprié et
que quand on veut construire un projet
pour rassembler les français
on va on est dans une période de crise
le tissu social se déchirent
il faut rassembler les français à une
élection partisane ne me paraît pas être
une bonne escient mais chacun appréciera
alors j'avais dit que c'était ma
dernière question j'avais menti c'était
mon avant dernier ressort une promesse
que les journalistes ne tient pas vous
ne verrez jamais la dernière la dernière
le 18 novembre dernier les militants
l'ump étaient appelés à voter non
seulement pour leur président mais
également pour les courants ce qui est
nouveau en fin de partie
bon il y avait 6 courant c'est la droite
forte qui est arrivé en premier le
courant le plus sarkozyste dont les
dirigeants disent qu'ils sont fiers
d'être français et de droite la droite
sociale de laurent wauquiez est arrivé
deuxième
la vôtre les humanistes uniquement
troisième est ce que vous êtes déçu
est ce que vous voyez une vous y voyez
une droitisation de l'ump
non parce qu'au fond la droite forte a
fait à peu près un tiers des voix à
peine un tiers et qu'au fond nous voilà
et nous nous sommes avec wauquiez à peu
près à 20% chacun donc on pèse 40%
profond vous avez droite sociale et
humaniste qui pèse 40 et vous avez la
droite force qui pèse 1,1 tiers donc au
total on voit que il est clair que et il
y à une droite puis centre dans l'ump
l'ump est un parti de droite et du
centre mais il est clair que la droite
est majoritaire par rapport au centre
dans l'ump c'est pour ça que avec le
centre il faut toujours qu'on joue un
peu des épaules pour
exister nos thèmes parce que est grosso
modo l'électorat de droite et
majoritaire dans l'ump
mais c'est toute la culture de l'ump
nous avons voulu nous rassemble et udf
et rpr pour être devant le front
national est de faire en sorte que si on
était divisée udf rpr
le front national seraient qualifiés au
second tour et nous on veut éviter à
notre candidat ce qui est arrivé à
monsieur jospin
c'est à dire l'élimination second tour
de l'élection présidentielle pour cela
il faut mettre la droite et le centre en
sang
c'est la logique de l'ump mais c'est
vrai j'ai des discussions entre gameplay
du délit de monsieur borloo
il ya des discussions bien sûr parce que
notamment à l'occasion des municipales
on a la volonté de pouvoir s'entendre et
donc pour le moment il est ouverte dont
celui des voilà il ya des primaires
ouvertes il ya quelques tiraillements
dans certaines villes mais au fond c'est
à peu près normal à cette période ce qui
compte c'est le moment venu on dégage
des candidatures quoi d'union
est-ce que rached adaptée doit maintenir
sa candidature à paris aux primaires
d'écriture des primaires c'est fait pour
être candidat je voudrais vous dire que
moi ce que je ne veux pas c'est que on
soit trop brutaux les uns et les autres
avec les différents candidats
je trouve quand même qu'il ya beaucoup
de brutalité qui s'expriment contre
rachida dati
je pense que nathalie kosciusko 1 de
grande qualité et de grande compétence
avoue-t-il brutalité vous évoquez les
propos de claude goasguen
je tenais un certain nombre de propos
ils sont ici ou là je pense que c'est
pas à la grandeur de tout le monde les
uns et les autres de d'avoir une
expression politique brutale et donc de
chacun à sa place chacun dans une
élection plus maire a le droit
la légitimité pour défendre ses idées
les électeurs arbitreront je pense que
nous avons avec nathalie kosciusko une
personnalité de qualité je souhaite
qu'elles puissent s'entendre avec
rachida dati leurs profils sont
différents
leur nature politique sont très
différentes leurs messages et leurs
tempéraments sont très différents je
pense que pour gagner arrive à
rassembler il faudra rassembler rachida
dati aussi en tout cas de ne pas avoir
de cible comme sac dont ils font l'objet
de toute les brutalités
merci beaucoup on avait joué on va
passer à la troisième partie de cette
émission va qu'on continue à parler des
élections intermédiaires les municipales
mais aussi les sénatoriales de septembre
2014 des élections qui vont
comptez le gouvernement vient d'ailleurs
de faire adopter une réforme du mode de
scrutin des élections sénatoriales
alors est ce qu il ya de quoi
compromettre les chances de faire
basculer la haute assemblée à droite on
voit tout de suite tout ça avec sandra
cerqueira la réforme du scrutin
sénatorial un projet de loi passée
presqu'inaperçue il rétablit la
proportionnelle supprimés par la droite
en 2002 pour les départements élisant
trois sénateurs et prévoit une meilleure
représentation des grandes communes un
rééquilibrage nécessaire selon la gauche
le corps électoral du sénat est
déséquilibrée puisque les communes
urbaines disons que les communes de plus
de 30000 habitants sont beaucoup moins
représentées au regard de leur
population mais ce rééquilibrage se fait
en maintenant les règles qui existent
pour les communes de vallet en
particulier le fait que chaque commune
disposera d'au moins un grand électeur
avec le retour de la proportionnelle la
droite pourrait perdre entre 5 et 10
sièges
voilà qui fait bondir l'opposition elle
dénonce un tripatouillage électoral la
gauche voudrait bien garder le sénat et
elle a peur des élections municipales
donc elle a regardé ce qu'elle pouvait
modifier dans le mode de scrutin pour
garder son avance qui vous le savez
n'est que de quelques sièges perdre la
majorité du sénat en 2014
ce serait un sacré coup de semonce une
réforme du mode de scrutin qui pourrait
aussi contrarié les espoirs de
reconquête de la droite les ambitions
personnelles aussi on parle d'un nouveau
duel entre gérard larcher l'ancien
président du sénat et jean pierre
raffarin candidat malheureux à la
présidence en 2008 sans doute désireux
de prendre sa revanche
gérard larcher aurait perdu quelques
soutiens mais pour certains si match
retour il y a il sera sans surprise
je pense que l'heure chez stratfor
larcher a fait le choix de fillon il a
70 % des sénateurs ump
fillon donc hélas il est sorti de la
période des pré dépressive post-défaite
réputé homme de terrain gérard larcher
serait déjà en campagne pour marquer des
points
jean pierre raffarin devra contrairement
à 2008 ne pas se contenter de chercher à
obtenir les soutiens du parti s'il voit
son avenir à la présidence du sénat
voilà donc pour aborder ces questions
liées aux sanctions
enfin bon soir alors si on en croit ces
curieux de gauche d'arbitraire débat à
droite pourtant c'est amusant
pas forcément en tout cas nous avons des
procédures que l'on vote en primaire à
l'intérieur de la majorité donc la
gauche ne ne pourront rien dans la
détermination des forces
le candidat il ya plus qu'un candidat
après jean canal est candidate dans le
groupe ump après il ya plus de candidats
mais les forces en présence
pavé des à choisir un candidat au sein
du groupe ump elle ne vote pas quand je
vous faudra vous dit quelque part que
tout ça vous intéresse donc la
présidence du sénat ça vous intéresse
encore ou pas c'est important sénat est
donc ce qui est important aujourd'hui
c'est que au fond la perte du sénat a
annoncé la perte de la présidentielle
peut être que la victoire du sénat
annoncera à la victoire de la
présidentielle
donc c'est un enjeu important sur la
route de 2010 est que cette étape de
2014 et donc sur les finances du sénat
aussi naturellement la présidence du
sénat sera un moment très fort parce que
s'il y a reconquis est du sénat ce sera
un message important sur la route de la
reconquête nationale mais le collège
électoral tel qu'il est applicable ou
impliqués ou sera appliquée en tout cas
demain pour 2014 on peut être la gauche
vous barre la route ou pas en tout cas
ce qui est clair c'est que la gauche a
bien compris l'importance du sénat
peut-être plus que de la droite ne
l'avez compris la dernière fois et donc
la gauche fait tout pour garder le sénat
hier vous avez remarqué qu'elles
changent toutes les élections
elle change toutes les règles du jeu
pour se maintenir au pouvoir il a changé
les élections municipales elle change
des élections cantonales
je change des élections régionales elles
changent les élections sénatoriales
elle chante à droite n'ont jamais tout
non mais non non non ne dites pas des
choses comme ça c'est inexact
la droite a modifié quelques élections
non c'est pas attaqué à l'ensemble du
paquet électoral pour être sûr que les
socialistes et des lois qui laisse
davantage à dire qu'à l'époque je vais
te fais pas donné jospin avait été
défait par la droite après oui ça nous
ce qu'on avait clairement dit parce que
nous le pensons profondément c'est que
la proportionnelle n'est pas quelque
chose pour le sénat de très juste parce
qu'on représente les collectivités
territoriales et tout ramener à des
étiquettes politiques
c'est pas toujours le sens des
territoires et aujourd'hui le sénat est
représentée par la moitié des élus à la
proportionnelle et par l'autre moitié
part au scrutin uninominal ça nous
paraissait un juste équilibre augmenter
la part des élus à la proportionnelle
nous paraît pas raisonnable et sa
politique de senna mais vous savez
l'histoire j'ai maintenant un petit peu
d'expérience
ceux qui jouent avec les règles
électorales sont toujours perdants c'est
pour ça que je peux nous avancer notre
victoire à victoire au sénat pour les
sénatoriales et pour les municipales
est-ce que selon vous parce qu'on a
beaucoup parlé des municipales pendant
cette démission est ce que selon vous
une vague bleue aux municipales est
possible ou est ce que ce sera une
vaguelette sans doute qu'en milieu
urbain
nous n'aurons pas tous les résultats que
nous espérons parce que là nous n'avons
pas toujours les équipes prête à
conquérir le pouvoir mais il ya un
certain nombre de villes sur lequel nous
avons beaucoup d'espoir je programme par
exemple à strasbourg on a un certain
nombre de villes qu'on peut reprendre
lorsque c'est le cas aussi à roanne d'un
certain nombre de perspectives mais en
tout cas pour toutes les communes
moyennes des petites villes et des
villages je pense que là on aura une
vague louis nicolas sarkozy pendant sa
campagne en 2012 avait dit la vague je
la sens monter là aussi vous si vous
pourriez dire la vague je la sens monter
pour les municipales écoutez quand vous
entendez le terrain par exemple sur la
réforme des rythmes scolaires le nombre
d'élus socialistes qui viennent à nos
réunions pour nous dire que cette
réforme est inacceptable peux vous dire
j'étais très surpris de voir le niveau
de contestation
et maire socialiste de l'action de
monsieur peillon donc quand je vois tout
cela je pense vraiment que l'électorat
socialiste
aujourd'hui est en train d'échapper au
fil de la contestation et non pas sur
vos projets je pense que hélas c'est
souvent le cas quand on est au pouvoir
quand vous regardez les élections
régionales nous avons gagné en 86 92 98
quand nous étions dans l'opposition
nous avons perdu en 2004 et en 2010
quand nous étions pouvoir c'est pour ça
que je pense que gagneront des
régionales de 2015 aussi hélas ce que
vous dites c'est que la réforme sur les
rythmes scolaires pourraient avoir le
même effet repoussoir que le délégué
territorial unique de nicolas sarkozy je
pense que d'une part la réforme des
rythmes faire et d'autre part cette
invention gadjé tic ignorant toutes les
réalités du terrain que l'élection du
binôme aux élections cantonales de
personnes sur un même territoire
ça va vraiment provoquer une agitation à
l'intérieur même des rangs socialistes
assez incroyable du monde le cumul des
mandats mais écoutez ça ça nous amuse de
voir un certain nombre de collègues
socialistes qui ont fait les tréteaux et
les chapiteaux pendant la campagne
électorale
applaudissant monsieur hollande qui
disait non au cumul et qui maintenant
veulent négocier avec lui comme si ce
type de proposition avait était
innocente de la campagne de monsieur
hollande
elle faisait partie de la campagne de
monsieur hollande on prend tout le
projet de monsieur hollande où on ne
prend pas le projet de monsieur hollande
les socialistes aujourd'hui donne un
piteux piteuse image de leur soutien au
président de la république en contestant
cette réforme sur le non cumul qui était
un engagement du président en janvier un
petit peu au sénat you know quotidien
libération a donné sur son site internet
une carte de france où près de cinquante
parlementaires en tout cas à ce jour ont
fait parvenir
l'utilisation de leur réserve
parlementaire est ce que vous seriez
prêt à rendre publics des chiffres de
votre réserve parlementaire
oui parce que d'ailleurs dans mon
département le connais puisque dans
toutes les inaugurations dans tous les
débats locaux quand on a un projet
chacun annonce le financement de son
projet donc il suffit de collectionner
les soutiens que nous et pendant ce
temps rien
j'ai aucun problème là dessus je pense
part je vois oui mais je dirais qu mais
ça c'est la responsabilité du maire
auquel on attribue si je veux le
communiqué ou pas le communiqué mais
c'est tout à fait faisable n'y a rien de
rien de caché là où c'est une démarche
publique ont écrit à la commission a
révélé la liste exacte des bénéficiaires
des projets de leurs réserves parlement
là on l'écouté il suffit d'aller sur le
terrain ce qui me concerne voir les
différentes mairies qui ont bénéficié de
mes soutiens c'est quelque chose de très
pur et je continue toujours sourire ça
donne souvent droit à faire un discours
sur le terrain et donc c'est l'occasion
d'exprimer clairement le soutien du
parlementaire alors s'il ya des
parlementaires qui ne souhaitent pas que
leurs actions soient connus ça les
regarde que moi je vous souhaite je
souhaite que mon action soit pauline
jean pierre raffarin vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure dans l'émission de ce
texte sur le mariage pour tous qui va
arriver au sénat mois d'avril il ya en
ce moment des auditions et le rapporteur
du texte jean pierre michel a décidé
tout simplement de ne pas auditionner le
collectif des mots au mariage pour tous
qui est engagée par frigide barjot d'une
part agenda trop chargé mais aussi les
accuse de dénis de nos phobies choqué
normal je trouve que c'est pas normal
car à porter ne voit pas tout le monde
bon c'est sa responsabilité
nous à l'ump nous avons reçues nous
avons reçu tout ce qu'ils avaient à
s'exprimer sur le sujet je pense que
quand on étudie un texte on doit
entendre tout le monde quand même et je
me 51 d'audition de la commission des
lois sur la tête je pense quand même que
c'est une erreur
ce texte là est vraiment une erreur et
je pense que ce sera un talon d'achille
du président de la république parce
qu'au fond c'est une une très profonde
division des français c'est un sujet
pour lequel les gens ont des convictions
très profonde
il est clair que le mot phobie est
vraiment pour moi une horreur
il est clair que tous ces débats peuvent
générer aussi de l'homophobie donc il
faut être très vigilant pour s'opposer à
l'homophobie parce que le sujet de
l'adoption n'est pas un sujet
aujourd'hui d'homophobie
il est clair qu'il faut pas faire
d'amalgamé et de ce point de vue là se
débat dans une crise sociale
de l'emploi traitant divise les français
et ce sera une cicatrice je pense dans
l'action de ce gouvernement
pour terminer cette émission jean pierre
raffarin quelle expérience vous avez
tiré la bataille de 2008 qui vous a vu
vous opposer à gérard larcher pour la
présidente la primaire au groupe ump en
vue de la présidence du sénat quelle
expérience on avait tiré
j'en ai déjà attiré beaucoup
d'expérience notamment que le rôle du
sénat et doit pouvoir s'exprimer avec
une certaine autorité compris vis-à-vis
de l'exécutif et je pense que il faut
même que finalement c'est un peu la même
situation aujourd'hui
le président du sénat doit pouvoir être
capable de s'opposer à un exécutif y
compris si l'exécutif et de ses propres
amis pour je pense que l'on n'entend pas
suffisamment le sénat et je trouve que
d'une manière générale et depuis un
certain temps l'exécutif gouvernemental
a trop pesé sur sur le sénat et le sénat
doit se faire entendre et de doigts pour
pouvoir exister avec sa propre autorité
sans être soumis à une autorité
politique qui à un moment ou un autre le
conduit à faire des erreurs
aucune maison fantôme le sénat est
devenue maintenant sous photoshop
silencieuse quand d'anciens à lens je
pense que le sénat doit veiller à son
autorité politique et donc le sénat doit
payer collectivement majorité-opposition
rassemblés à son autorité à son
indépendance politique et je pense que
nous avons eu à la tête du sénat des
personnes de qualité
je pense que le président bayle est
quelqu'un de très respectables et de
très estimable mines nommé à l'intérieur
du son du débat à gauche on n'entend pas
suffisamment le sait très bien entendu
votre message jean pierre raffarin à
jean pierre bel le président du sénat
merci d'avoir était aujourd'hui l'invité
de preuves par 3 merci michael
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis très
bonne soirée et sur l'antenne de public
sénat
ce qu'on attribue à nicolas sarkozy
c'est celle ci je lui ai donné des
jouets alors il parle du conseil général
des hauts-de-seine et puis depuis ce
matin l'ump qu'il s'est empressé de
casser patrick devedjian est au courant
de cette phrase elle vous aimeront
monsieur les lieux dans le journal mais
je n'ai jamais entendu une seule comme
étant l'ennemi voir le souffre-douleur
de nicolas sarkozy depuis sa réélection
dans les hauts-de-seine fin 2012 patrick
devedjian fait figure de revenants alors
comment vit-il cette revanche comment at
il survécu à cette lutte acharnée et
peut-on comme il l'a toujours fait
manier l'humour et la provocation dans
la vie politique cette semaine ou des
visions en tout bien tout honneur le
plus caustique des politiques
déshabillons n'est demain à 18h15 sur
public sénat
on a cherché des anomalies détectées
matin j'ai regardé ici ils savent étant
le cinquième doit calculer les parents
la cassine mans une interruption
médicale de grossesse à l'échographie
ont strictement rien dire mon rôle dans
leur expliquer clairement ce qu'il
manquait au niveau des membres grâce aux
avancées de la médecine
on peut maintenant détecter les
malformations et les pathologies des
enfants in utero mais après que faut-il
faire
à l'hôpital robert debré à paris les
médecins et les parents sont face au
choix de l'interruption médicale de
grossesse elle soit pour la vie samedi à
15h15 sur public sénat
tablettes smartphones internet mobile le
numérique est partout et même dans
l'esprit de françois hollande c'est le
quatrième engagement de son programme
présidentiel
une ambition numérique qui passe par
l'installation du réseau très haut débit
en france le réseau thd 50% du
territoire couvert dans 5 ans 100 % dans
dix ans une révolution technologique
pour soigner la fracture numérique
car aujourd'hui en france le réseau
internet coller des faiblesses la france
est en train de prendre un retard
considérable par rapport au reste du
monde et même à l'intérieur de la zone
européenne par rapport aux peuples de
l'est nous sommes en train de prendre du
retard
aux côtés de son collègue ump pierre
hérisson
le sénateur yves rome s'est vu confier
une mission d'information par le sénat
fixer les conditions de cette
numérisation du territoire le très haut
débit une priorité un élément
indispensable pour bien vivre dans les
territoires au même titre que l'eau ou
l'électricité mais aussi une révolution
économique la fibre peut redonner de
l'attractivité à la france relancer la
compétitivité
il faut aller très vite à la vitesse de
la lumière à la vitesse de la fibre
le très haut débit par la fibre c'est
une aubaine pour un secteur celui des
entreprises le e-commerce
le commerce sur internet est en plein
boom comme ici dans l'oise
chez alfa direct service le numéro un de
la logistique en e-commerce
après votre shopping sur internet c'est
ici que vos commandes sont traitées
emballé et expédiée est ici qu'arrivent
la fibre optique qui a changé en fait le
le fonctionnement de l'entreprise et qui
nous a permis de recueillir de plus en
plus des e-commerçants elle de gérer de
plus en plus de commandes par jour et
pour se rendre compte de l'impact du thd
sur les communications de l'entreprise
visite du sénateur rome
ici le volume de données de plus en plus
importants grâce à la fibre
le chiffre d'affaires d'adp et s a
triplé la fibre optique nous a permis de
développer notre activité et de
développer nos process pour gérer de
plus en plus de commandes par heure
et de la meilleure façon également pour
les employés et de traiter le la
commande le plus simplement possible
la fibre optique et l'optimisation des
process en interne nous permet
aujourd'hui de gérer plus de 9000
commandes par heure avant la fibre
c'était 100 commandes par jour
une véritable révolution et ce n'est pas
le numéro un de la vente en ligne de
chaussures qui dira le contraire
le site spécialisé a trouvé chez eads
une efficacité pour ses clients une
rapidité d'exécution
un client sarenza peut commander jusqu'à
15 heures et il recevra son colis le
lendemain matin avec la fibre et avec
l'ensemble des fonctionnalités que l'on
met en place c'est des pros c'est ce que
l'on met en place au niveau de nos
entrepôts on est capable aujourd'hui de
concurrencer les plus gros sites
e-commercants du monde en termes de
logistique très haut débit fibre optique
qu'est ce que c'est c'est un fil de
verre très fin
enveloppé dans une gaine de protection
sa capacité véhicule est un signal
lumineux à la vitesse de la lumière
la différence avec les anciens câble
type adsl c'est le débit 100 fois plus
élevés sur des milliers de kilomètres
aujourd'hui en france on compte deux
cent cinquante mille abonnés à la fibre
optique
quand certains pays ont déjà achevé
leurs déploiements
et pour comprendre les enjeux au sénat
yves rome reçoit les acteurs de la
filière
aujourd'hui il auditionne les fabricants
et installateurs de fibres on voit très
bien de votre monde vu des réseaux fibre
optique et infrastructures à fibre
optique et les services associés et
services très haut débit associés comme
un enjeu équivalent à celui de
l'électrification de pays au début du
20e siècle bon comparé en fabrique des
câbles électriques
on a un bon parallèle devant nous et on
voit très bien comment se sont
structurés
réseau électrique dans les 50 dernières
années et comment devrait se structurer
les réseaux fibre optique selon ces
industriels
cette technologie est indispensable dans
chaque foyer français
quand vous avez la fille chez vous c'est
mon cas vous voyez pourquoi vous en avez
besoin
tout simplement ça arrêtez de vous
arrêter de vous disputer avec vos
enfants etc pour savoir qui trafiquent
terra corsa dirais que c'est le petit le
petit bout de la lorgnette
c'est celle c'est le sait la vision déjà
actuelle mais alors demain on n'en parle
même pas aujourd'hui dans le monde juste
derrière les leaders japonais et
américains en matière de fabrication
les français sont depuis longtemps près
il est vrai qu'en france je serais
aujourd'hui c'était une ancienne usine
alcatel
groupe c une usine qui a développé à
l'époque plus de 300 brevets actifs
seulement 64 et qui sont toujours actifs
il ya un vrai savoir faire et la france
là dessus est très très bien positionné
nous avons la maîtrise d'une technologie
du futur ma part essentielle aujourd'hui
sur le territoire national nous donnions
l'occasion six industriels de développer
leur savoir faire pour que derrière les
usages se déploie massivement et que